[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir bienvenue dans sens
public votre rendez-vous quotidien de
débat et de reportage sur Public Sénat
en étant ensemble tous les jours du
lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
invités experts et tous les mois grâce à
nos partenaires audoxa mascara en vos
propose ce baromètre qui scrute la
popularité et les traits d'images des
personnalités politiques et en premier
lieu du président de la République trop
brutale inapte au dialogue éloigné de
leur préoccupations voilà comment une
large majorité de Français qualifiée
Emmanuel Macron et c'est dans ce
contexte
ultra négatif qui est le multiplie les
déplacements sur le terrain comme
aujourd'hui à Vendôme on analysera cette
stratégie de reconquête dans une minute
et puis pour notre débat de société vous
savez volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour c'est un zoom sur
les pesticides que je vous propose avec
des agriculteurs qui en ont marre d'être
montré du doigt
c'est énervant comment on va te soulever
le matin et puis dire que bah il y a des
gens ils croient qu'on est là pour les
intoxiquer les polluer entre nous c'est
pas notre but nous c'est de faire
pousser une plante qu'elle soit saine et
de la récolter pour nourrir la
population
quels sont les dangers sanitaires liés
aux pesticides peut-on s'en passer et
réussir à nourrir près de 10 milliards
d'humains en 2050 les interdits français
sont-ils plus nombreux et plus strictes
que dans d'autres pays d'Europe on
répond à toutes ces questions dans 45
minutes mais d'abord le constat d'un duo
exécutif en mal d'amour avec
matthiasarayz
une impopularité qui lui colle à la peau
malgré une volonté affichée de tourner
la page des retraites Emmanuel Macron
stagne dans l'estime des Français 70%
d'entre eux pensent qu'il est un mauvais
président un taux qui n'évolue pas par
rapport au mois dernier pire le Chef de
l'État est brutal pour 65 % des Français
pour le qualificatif compétent Emmanuel
Macron ne convainc plus que 36% des
sondés c'est 13 points de moins qu'au
moment de sa réélection il y a un an
enfin ils ne sont que 17% à estimer que
le Président de la République est proche
de leur préoccupation pour Elisabeth
borne le constat et le même 28%
d'opinion favorables une donnée stable
depuis le mois dernier seul Manuel Valls
en 2016 pendant la loi travail était
descendu plus bas pour 61% des Français
la locataire de Matignon n'est pas
compétente c'est 31 points de plus qu'au
moment de sa nomination 72
l'estime fermé au dialogue et pour 66%
d'entre eux elle ne peut plus rester à
la tête du gouvernement
et on va reprendre ces chiffres
évidemment les détailler les analyser
avec Céline braque bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes directrice générale d'odoxa
Mathieu souker bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi consultant essayiste spécialisé en
sciences politiques Jean-Sébastien
Ferjoux bonsoir bienvenue Jean Sébastien
fondateur directeur d'Atlantico avec
nous également en duplex
ifs et le Seigneur partner de mascaret
qui est scrute donc les les réseaux
sociaux les médias sociaux dans le cadre
de ce baromètre bonsoir et bienvenue
Émilie appelle ski éditorialiste à mes
côtés comme
deux fois par semaine une fois par
semaine depuis depuis quelques mois
bienvenue à vous Emilie premier constat
c'est une braque on va revoir certains
des chiffres qui ont été donnés issus de
ce baromètre qui est en partenariat avec
Public Sénat et aussi la presse
régionale vous retrouvez ces résultats
dans vos quotidiens ou dans vos
magazines régionaux les Français sont
pas passés à autre chose si on veut
réussir une phrase dans
le sujet on disait le président veut
tourner la page c'est très clairement ce
qu'il montre ce qu'il veut mais non les
Français ça leur reste en travers de la
gorge j'entendais qu'à l'Elysée on
disait ok de toute façon on va arrêter
le les mesures salées on va passer au
sucré mais c'est un peu comme si les
gens avaient fait n'avaient pas supporté
le plat de résistance qui faisait une
grosse indigestion et qu'on leur disait
et maintenant le dessert et non en fait
on a plus faim c'est trop tôt on veut
faire une pause et donc le fait de voir
le président comme ça tout le temps tous
les jours même s'il leur annonce que on
est passé au dessert et bien ça ne passe
pas et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
popularité du président elle est elle
est faible enfin il y a 70% de mauvaises
opinions 30% de bonnes opinions ça ça
n'a pas envie
qu'on le baromètre c'est c'est moi par
mois sur ce niveau de popularité
le mois dernier il a perdu petits points
il a perdu 11 points depuis l'annonce de
la réforme des retraites pour Elisabeth
borne elle a perdu plus vite du terrain
et là elle stagne ce sont des niveaux
bas et
derrière cela alors on rentrera sans
doute dans le détail tout à l'heure mais
on voit qu'il y a beaucoup de
qualificatifs alors on peut en retenir
un extrêmement sévère quand même qui
ressort et ça faut que vous nous
détailler effectivement le résultat sur
ce trade d'image spécifiquement voilà
c'est à dire que il est dynamique ça les
Français le disent 55% il est dynamique
mais ils sont 65% à dire c'est quelqu'un
de brutal c'est 16 points de plus depuis
son élection ça veut dire que le
comparatif est sur un an on est bien
d'accord excusez-moi oui là c'est sur un
an ça veut dire que c'est déjà quelque
chose qui lui était quand même attribué
c'est-à-dire le fait que ce soit
quelqu'un qui passe en force mais cette
réforme des retraites c'est vraiment le
symbole de la réf que l'on passe au
forceps que l'on impose il y a aussi un
autre attribut qui est le fait que les
Français considèrent qu'il n'est pas
ouvert au dialogue 80% des Français le
disent et c'est vrai qu'il a beau lui
aller sur le terrain en disant moi
vous vous bouchez les oreilles mais en
fait à la au départ c'est à lui qu'on
reproche cela oui on y reviendra en
détail sur ces autres traits de d'image
Mathieu Suker si on prend un peu de
recul historiquement de toute façon on
le sait bien les réformes des retraites
rendent rarement l'exécutif populaire
mais est-ce qu'il y a là une dimension
supplémentaire justement avec vous
l'évoquiez cet empilement de d'outils
d'efficacité constitutionnelle on
pourrait appeler ça comme ça qui sont
tous légaux mais qui ont été qui se sont
succédés est-ce que est-ce que il y a il
y a ce grand supplémentaire dans
j'allais dire la détestation c'est
peut-être un peu fort mais on en est pas
loin pour ça non je crois pas que ce
soit fort justement le pouvoir est une
école un popularité de ce point de vue
là il y a pas de surprise il n'y a pas
de nouveautés alors l'impopularité d'une
première ministre ou d'un président de
la République ça vaut pas la même chose
parce qu'une première ministre on peut
la remercier et la remplacer donc c'est
pas un problème insoluble d'un
popularité à Matignon l'impopularité à
l'Elysée c'est plus compliqué et même si
pour le coup il y a des précédents en
matière de d'un popularité et de
défiance et même on a tous ressorti les
cotes concernant Nicolas Sarkozy
François Hollande etc il y a eu parfois
pire que Emmanuel Macron il y a
effectivement une spécificité qui
concerne Emmanuel Macron il y a la
défiance mais il y a la défiance avec la
longévité c'est-à-dire que les niveaux
de défiance atteints par ces
prédécesseurs c'était en deuxième partie
de quinquennat en deuxième partie de
mandat et à l'approche d'un rendez-vous
démocratique qui était la future
élection présidentielle là le problème
c'est que on ne fait pas le premier
anniversaire de Macron à l'Élysée mais
le sixième anniversaire d'Emmanuel
Macron on les disait donc le niveau de
défiance il intervient beaucoup plus tôt
que d'habitude et par ailleurs si on
compare simplement avec son prédécesseur
c'est une défiance qui ne génère pas
comme avec François Hollande dont la
présidence était dit normale où en fait
très horizontale par rapport à celle
d'Emmanuel Macron François Hollande
quand ça marchait l'opinion le
considérait comme plutôt sympathique
alors je sais pas si c'est une qualité
qui est importante pour un chef d'État
mais les gens le trouvaient plutôt sympa
parce qu'il ressemblait à tout le monde
et puis quand ça s'est inversé les gens
ont trouvé à tort ou à raison nul et du
coup le sentiment suscité c'est du
mépris c'est ce que j'allais dire je ne
sais pas ce qu'il vaut mieux choisir
entre le mépris la détestation mais on
voit bien que dans le contexte en tout
cas la détestation que la présidence
ultraverticule est ultra verticale
d'Emmanuel Macron suscite à quelque
chose de d'inédit et de dangereux
l'ancien candidat europécologie les
Verts à l'élection présidentielle
Yannick Jadot va jusqu'à parler d'une
dérive in libérale d'Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que vous jugez ce qualificatif
exagéré
on n'est pas tout à fait quand même au
niveau de la Hongrie en revanche je
pense que oui on est entré sur un chemin
quand on voit en terme de rest des
libertés publiques on l'avait déjà connu
au moment du covid sans que ce soit
proportionné à de véritables exigences
ou en tout cas efficacité sanitaire et
là on le voit regardez aujourd'hui les
manifestations avaient encore été
interdites et elles ont le l'arrêté
préfectoral a été annulé par le tribunal
administratif je pense qu'en termes de
liberté publique oui à quelque chose
d'inquiétant dans ce que le gouvernement
est en train de mettre en œuvre même si
évidemment que même s'il allait plus
loin nous serions encore très très loin
de la dictature mais je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose de très personnel avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est une détestation
personnelle elle n'est pas très
politique est-ce que c'était pas déjà ça
avec Nicolas Sarkozy pas mais justement
non justement politique que personne
Nicolas Sarkozy pouvait irriter les gens
mais il y avait quand même toujours la
gauche et la droite donc il y avait
quand même des jambes droites qui
continuent alors ils pouvaient irriter
aussi parfois chez certains à droite
mais ça s'inscrivait quand même dans un
paysage politique parce que là il y a
quelque chose moi je trouve qu'il y a
une règle non écrite de la démocratie
dont on parle assez peu pour que la
démocratie fonctionne il faut pas
uniquement respecter les institutions il
faut que l'al commence par est-ce
possible et là parce qu'Emmanuel Macron
a nié le clivage gauche droite parce que
il a essayé de lui substituer un clivage
les raisonnable contre les déraisonnable
les le cercle de la raison contre les
populistes les démagogues les
extrémistes et que sais-je comme
qualificatifs qui discréditent
absolument les autres ils ne considère
pas que ce sont des adversaires
politiques ils considèrent que ce sont
des dangers et là dans la mesure où il y
a par ailleurs une espèce de
tripartition du paysage politique
français vous avez un bloc à gauche qui
a l'impression qui n'arrivera jamais au
pouvoir et vous avez un bloc à droite
qui se sent exclu aussi du pouvoir et
donc ça détestation qui l'entretient
parce que c'est comme si elle était à
hauteur d'homme en quelque sorte quand
les gens lui répond on voit bien c'est
comme s'il y avait vraiment un lien
quand il a dit qu'il était prêt emmerder
les noms vaccinés ou un certain nombre
de ces petites phrases c'est quelque
chose que les gens prennent pour eux ils
ne le prennent pas pour eux comme je
suis de gauche et je suis agacé par un
président de droite ou réciproquement
ils le prennent comme quelque chose
vraiment sur un terrain interpersonnel
c'est Emmanuel Macron lui-même qui les
aurait-il dans un paysage de ruines
politiques et ça c'est inquiétant
aussi il y a un autre à prendre en
compte c'est que prenons pendant son
premier quinquennat finalement il a eu
tout de suite eu cette image président
des riches un peu brutale justement ISF
suppression d'ISF et puis très
rapidement on a quand même eu le covid
suivi ensuite par la guerre en Ukraine
et du coup c'est devenu plutôt
l'État-providence gilet jaune
et dans ces moments-là il a été plutôt
un président protecteur qui a donné qui
a donné du pouvoir d'achat au gilet
jaune ce qu'il a donné 17 milliards et
qui a protégé les Français pendant le
covid en fait il a pris une autre
casquette que les gens ont pris
finalement puisque ils sont mis sous sa
coupe covid oblige on a suivi tout ce
qui tout ce qui demandait donc il a eu
une image complètement différente et là
avec la réforme des retraites ça y est
on a le Emmanuel Macron
des premiers vrai Emmanuel Macron et ça
je pense que les gens on entend cette
petite musique du président des riches
de celui qui qui cautionne les intérêts
économiques des plus riches des plus
âges et des plus riches ça revient cette
petite musique comme si ça avait été un
petit peu gommé et ça je pense que les
gens ne le pardonnent pas d'autant plus
qu'il a distribué énormément et que là
tout d'un coup pour 12 milliards d'euros
par an il va faire toute une réforme qui
est en effet très brutalement mise en
oeuvre et imposé je voudrais qu'on
regarde Céline les les traits d'image de
la première ministre on a vu le chiffre
générale elle est à peine moins un
populaire que le Président de la
République que disent les Français que
vous avez sonder tiens par exemple de ça
de sa compétence de sa capacité au
dialogue qu'est-ce qui ressort Elisabeth
elle ressemble quand on compare les
qualificatifs avec ceux d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est très proche elle est
toutefois jugée moins brutale alors on
est à 53% on est à 65% donc on est à 65
% pour Emmanuel Macron mais pour le
reste c'est quand même très mauvais
c'est à dire que sur sa compétence on
acide Français sur 10 qui trouve qu'elle
est pas compétence avec une chute
vertigineuse en un an 31 points de perte
de 1 an
32 points de perte sur le dynamisme pour
le coup elle est pas jugée dynamique
contrairement à Emmanuel Macron
elle est considérée comme pas ouverte au
dialogue 72% des Français le disent et
ça a baissé 24 points c'est vrai qu'elle
a été vendue entre guillemets parce que
beaucoup de gens la connaissaient pas
comme étant la première ministre qui
pourrait parler au syndicat et donc les
Français ils se disaient après tout
pourquoi pas bon là
vraisemblablement ils sont plus trop
taper de cet avis là elle n'est pas jue
comme quelqu'un de sympathique 74% des
gens la trouvent pas sympathique pas
proche des préoccupations des Français
76% moins 17 points ce qui fait que elle
non plus la question de son avenir ça
c'est intéressant quand on demande la
question c'est peut-elle rester Premier
ministre voilà tout à l'heure et la
réponse c'est non à 66 % sachant que
c'est logique 64% elle peut pas réformer
le pays donc ça va quand même un peu
ensemble c'est pour pour Elisabeth borde
ça a baissé très très vite mais c'est
elle c'est très vite rendue impopulaire
elle a protégé un petit peu le président
au début et puis au moment de la réforme
des retraites patatras Emmanuel Macron a
perdu aussi énormément de terrain donc
c'est vraiment la première ministre qui
en ce moment ne permet plus du tout de
d'accaparer une part de d'un popularité
qui pourrait protéger le
aux choses qui sont pas des réformes en
fait mais des par exemple augmentation
des salaires des enseignants le fait que
on ne perd plus de points quand on fait
un petit excès de vitesse ce genre de de
d'annonce là de vrai être lui mettre à
son crédit ou être mise au crédit
d'Emmanuel Macron et bien ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
un moment c'est vraiment un moment où
les gens considèrent que tout ça c'est
de la com tout ça c'est plus marketing
et voilà alors
le prénom la République il a donné à sa
première ministre la mission d'élargir
sa majorité et 100 jours pour faire
avancer c'est trois chantiers
prioritaires c'est quoi c'est de
l'incantation
alors je sais pas en toutes les tas de
cause il y avait dans l'identité
politique initiale je sais pas si
peut-être un peu excessif de parler
d'identité politique mais d'Elizabeth
borne effectivement la compétence on est
juste une femme compétente femme de
dossier qui va tenir les choses etc et
puis c'est une femme de dialogue puis on
a ajouté même elle vient de la gauche
bon le problème c'est que sa compétence
a été mise à rude épreuve son sens du
dialogue également et puis à la portée
une réforme qu'on peut difficilement
associer à la gauche quant au Cap
politique précisément et à la feuille de
route que lui donne le président de la
République la difficulté tient quand
même au fait que on ne sait plus très
bien où on va il y a une ultra
plasticité du macronisme mais je me
souviens que au lendemain de sa
domination enfin le jour de sa
nomination dans un tweet le président de
la République nous souhaitait bonne
chance et lui disait un planification
écologique deux écoles trois santé et
donc on voit que en fait neuf mois après
le sept feuille de route là c'est
priorité politique là non pas du tout
non pas du tout été respectées à chaque
intervention de président change de
priorité exactement y compris dans ces
trois interventions récentes donc
forcément on s'y perd et je pense que
l'ultra verticalité sur la forme est
l'ultra plasticité sur le fond finit
aussi par se payer et la première
ministre ont subi elle-même les
conséquences sur la mission ou la
feuille de route effectivement donnée à
l'après-midi je veux bien je veux bien
entendre votre avis Jean
sébastien-ferjou disait c'est un quant à
toi c'est à dire que enfin c'était
mission impossible on l'a dit des
dizaines de fois depuis depuis 15 jours
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez au mieux
c'est un exercice un peu sadique enfin
parce que non mais franchement lui
demander de présenter une feuille de
route dans le contexte actuel enfin
c'est absurde et au pire et je pense que
c'est là le plus grave c'est encore une
fois démonétiser c'est l'escalade dans
la démonétisation de la parole publique
à quoi ça rime de donner une feuille de
route à quelqu'un dans un contexte
politique ou de toute façon elle ne peut
pas la déployer quoi qu'il en soit il
n'y aura pas de majorité élargie ignorer
vraisemblablement pas de majorité par
projet et la majorité elle-même la
majorité relative celle qui soutient le
gouvernement est elle-même en plein
trouble donc c'est totalement absurde de
faire comme si tout ça n'existait pas et
moi je trouve que c'est inquiétant parce
qu'on voit des interventions du
Président de la République il fait des
promesses le sujet n'est pas la promesse
en soi mais alors là dans Le Parisien on
va maintenant isoler toutes les écoles
mais souvenez-vous il y avait un
dimanche c'était réveillé il voulait
construire des RER dans toutes les
métropoles de France à chaque fois il y
a pas de plan de financement pas de
calendrier il y a pas de concertation
avec les gens qui sont censés prendre
des décisions les prisons de région ou
les machins et peu importe il nous fait
des annonces quand même et c'est grave
d'un point de vue démocratique c'est
grave de démonétiser ça très bien à son
époque je pense qu'il y avait un peu
plus de fonds politiques et de
négociations quand même il y avait une
majorité il y avait un gouvernement il y
avait des personnalités qui pouvaient
s'opposer au président là on voit bien
que ça n'est pas le cas parce que le bon
de touche du macronisme il est très
faible et la promesse initiale au-delà
de la plasticité idéologique la promesse
initiale c'était quoi c'était ok je vais
vous débarrasser de la gauche et la
droite parce que c'est un gars ils sont
tous nuls machin etc mais on va être
efficace mais non il n'a pas été
efficace et la brutalité la brutalité
oui absolument la brute la perception de
la brutalité elle vient de là quand vous
prétendez savoir mieux que tout le monde
bah ça marche peut-être si vous êtes
efficace mais là les Français ont sous
les yeux d'école capital l'énergie alors
bien que ça ne marche pas donc
l'incompétence plus le fait de ne
consulter personne ben oui c'est perçu
comme de la parité on n'a pas encore
donné la parole à Yves Sancy pour se
tourner vers la partie réseau sociaux
médias sociaux de ce baromètre au doxa
mascara avec un prénom République qui
avait été plutôt discret volontairement
je dis plutôt indiscret voltairement
pendant trois mois là il revient en
force à quel niveau de présence dans les
réseaux sociaux si on compare les
époques
tout à fait une présence
totale si j'ose dire c'est à dire que si
on observe les conversations sur les
réseaux sociaux comme on le fait on voit
bien qu'il y a un moment
de changement c'est ce qu'on a appelé
l'effet 49-3 et cet effet 49-3 avant il
y avait une relative absence des manuels
Macron sur la scène intérieure depuis il
y a une présence totale avec on l'a dit
une contestation à la fois personnelle
puisque on va dire que c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui fait l'objet de tous les
ressentiments à la fois sur la question
de la réforme mais également sur la
pratique du gouvernement
mais je dirais que
on a une montée du champ lexical
qui va vers une radicalisation très très
forte et qui marque quelque chose de
nouveau quand même
cette radicalisation et cette
contestation elle n'est pas
institutionnelle en réalité il n'y a pas
de contestation institutionnel mais par
contre elle est sur une personnalité et
sur la pratique de gouvernement quand je
dis sur la pratique de gouvernement
c'est que ce 49-3 et ce qui s'en est
suivi et peut-être aussi une stratégie
qui a consisté à dire
le gouvernement et le président sont du
côté des institutions or il n'y a pas
d'attaque de légitimité institutionnelle
mais politique ça a été noté tout à
l'heure le gouvernement n'a pas de
majorité c'est aussi peut-être qui ont
fait sa faiblesse politique mais
on se retrouve dans une situation où il
n'y a pas de contestation
institutionnelle par contre on a une
violence de plus en plus forte sur les
évocations autour d'Emmanuel Macron et
également de la la pratique de la
manière d'utiliser les institutions
c'est un peu comme si les conversations
étaient autour du fait que le
gouvernement n'aurait pas respecté les
règles du jeu et il y a un fond respect
des règles de des règles du jeu mais les
Français considèrent que autant les
syndicats et peut-être même les
oppositions à partir moi les oppositions
de gauche ce qui est une surprise se
retrouve dans une situation au centre de
présentation et en respecter les règles
du jeu en tant composant mais le
gouvernement ne l'aurait pas fait et
Emmanuel Macron ne les aurait pas
respecté non merci revient vers vous
tout à l'heure malgré la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui ont le
rappelle à valider un fait la procédure
et l'essentiel de la réforme on va
parler de la stratégie
d'Emmanuel Macron stratégie de
communication je propose à Steve
Jourdain de nous rejoindre bonsoir Steve
bienvenue à vous on le sait Emmanuel
Macron s'est donné 100 jours pour
apaiser et continuer de réformer les
deux en même temps il était en
déplacement dans le Loir-et-Cher
aujourd'hui la nouvelle fois été
chaudement accueilli oui déplacement
sous haute sécurité ce mardi dans la
ville de Vendôme le chef de l'État a
visité une maison de santé pour ce
troisième déplacement présidentiel
depuis son allocution il y a une semaine
on rappelle que jeudi dernier il était
dans le département de l'Hérault ou des
manifestants et des syndicalistes là on
est sur place pour l'occasion le préfet
du département avait décidé d'interdire
les casseroles et aujourd'hui rebelote
un arrêté a été pris par son homologue
du Loir-et-Cher avec une petite
particularité cette fois puisque non
seulement les casseroles ont été
interdites mais aussi les rassemblements
revendicatifs l'arrêter se base sur la
législation entité fleuriste est
considère que l’interdiction de se
rassembler et justifier au regard du
fait que le président représente une
cible symbolique je précise que s'est
arrêté a été suspendu en fin de journée
par la justice la manifestation a quand
même eu lieu mais à distance de la
maison de santé que visiter Emmanuel
Macron et alors c'est rassemblement
bruyant c'est aussi une façon de fêter
les un an de la réélection d'Emmanuel
Macron oui il est un an de la réaction
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était hier pour
l'occasion des concerts de casseroles
étaient organisés un peu partout en
France ils ont réuni parfois plusieurs
centaines de personnes à Rennes on va le
voir les manifestants se sont retrouvés
devant la mairie à Marseille ils se sont
donnés rendez-vous avec des casseroles
et des ustensiles de cuisine sur le
vieux port même chose à Lyon ou encore à
Paris devant l'hôtel de ville ou le
rassemblement avéré à la manifestation
sauvage le mot d'ordre c'est toujours le
même depuis une semaine non à la réforme
des retraites promulguées par le chef de
l'État écouter
peux pas écouter le peuple donc il veut
pas il veut pas écouter le fait que les
gens appellent à la démission donc il
faudrait que déjà qu'il essaie de
changer radicalement de de voir qu'il
ouvre pas la voix aux extrêmes droites
comme il est en train de le faire et qui
et qui s'engagent dans ce qu'il a dans
ce qu'il a promis dans dans le système
social qu'il a promis d'améliorer les
déplacements des ministres sont
également ciblés la visite à Lyon du
ministre de l'éducation nationale a été
fortement très fortement perturbé hier
pas pay Ndiaye se rendait à l'Institut
national du professeur et de l'éducation
une centaine de manifestants vous le
voyez la tendez sur place on va écouter
l'un d'entre eux
comme tout ministre sera poursuivi par
les bruits de casseroles tant qu'ils
auront pas retiré leur réforme et puis
deuxième élément on a quand même un gros
sujet de contentieux en ce moment avec
le ministre sur la question de la
revalorisation des personnels au lieu
d'éducation nationale et donc du coup on
tenait à signaler à l'occasion de sa
venue
son retour à Paris même comité d'accueil
dans le hall de la gare de Lyon on va le
voir sur les images Thomas le ministra
finalement pu être exfiltré de la gare
sans passer devant les manifestants
alors plusieurs autres ministres ont été
chahutés ces dernières heures la
secrétaire d'État à l'enfance charlotte
cobel a même du renoncé hier à un
déplacement prévu dans le Val-de-Marne
motif son dispositif de sécurité n'était
pas tout à fait au point pour faire face
à ces manifestants merci Steve pour pour
ces explications on reviendra sur ces
concerts de casseroles dans un instant
mais mais on reste concentré là sur la
stratégie de communication des balles
Macron je vous propose d'écouter une
analyse celle de Philippe Moreau
Chevrolet communicant et professeur en
communication politique à Sciences Po
l'idée d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de
provoquer une nouveauté par jour ça peut
passer par un clash par une petite
phrase l'idée c'est d'occuper le terrain
le plus possible et que comme c'est le
président tous les regards en France
convergent vers le président donc on va
parler que de ça ça c'est le contexte la
description Émilie on a eu le grand
débat là c'est des petits débats c'est
ça oui si vous avez aimé le grand débat
national vous allez adorer les petits
débats d'Emmanuel Macron alors il faut
dire qu'on a déjà commencé à le voir
dans cet exercice depuis plusieurs jours
depuis en fait la validation de la
réforme par le Conseil constitutionnel
on l'a vu donc en Alsace le 19 avril il
parlait de réindustrialisation puis
après dans l'Hérault comme c'était
souligné la partie le 20 avril sur le
thème de l'éducation et comme le disait
justement Steve toujours avec ce concert
de casserole qui le suivait on va
visionner d'ailleurs un extrait de l'une
de ses prestations donc c'était sur le
thème de l'éducation dans l'Hérault
alors regardez bien Macron qui parle les
autres autour de lui qui écoutent on est
vraiment dans un remake du grand débat
national
et donc le pacte c'est de dire et nous
on fait le pari qui a au moins un tiers
des enseignants qui adhérents
c'est de dire les tâches que toutes les
missions que vous voulez faire en plus
pour qu'elles soient pérennisées faut
que le système les reconnaisse et les
paye mieux et donc là en plus de cette
augmentation du socle entre 100 et 230
euros par mois selon les moments de la
carrière il y aura justement quelque
chose qui sera fait en plus c'est défini
avec le chef d'établissement sur une
base totalement volontaire et qui va
permettre de payer encore plus par mois
ce qui permettra des enseignants de
toucher jusqu'à 500 euros par mois en
plus voilà on a toutes les explications
techniques c'était pareil au grand débat
national il y avait toutes les éléments
aujourd'hui donc sur les déserts
médicaux dans le Loir-et-Cher le but
l'objectif de ces déplacements et de ses
annonces alors le principe c'est simple
faire passer la pilule de la réforme des
retraites qui n'est décidément pas passé
en multipliant les contacts avec la
population et puis en multipliant les
annonces durant ces 100 jours
d'apaisement et d'action l'Élysée
prévoit de déplacements par semaine de
ce type le Président il est en est
convaincu il la redit si les choses se
passent mal c'est parce qu'il n'a pas
été assez présent pour défendre
plateforme alors il faut comprendre en
creux que les autres les ministres et
puis la première ministre n'ont pas fait
le job en quelque sorte pourtant si on
regarde bien toutes les critiques le
cible personnellement donc quelque part
cette personnalisation sur la réforme de
retraite elle s'est fait volontairement
ou pas en tout cas il est bien là est-ce
que son pari peut réussir alors ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que Emmanuel Macron il
est souvent très bon dans cet exercice
en plus il aime ça Dieu dans les yeux
convaincre chacun des bienfaits de son
action de sa politique et de ses
résultats à venir même de sa méthode
mais bon la démarche a donc des airs de
déjà-vu avec des résultats pour le grand
débat national qui était pas forcément à
la hauteur des attentes le grand débat
il sait pas soldé avec des mesures qui
ont été très frappantes et puis point
important il avait été lancé plutôt avec
succès au départ mais à un moment où le
président avait lâché il avait lâché la
hausse de la taxe carburant qui avait
été l'émandé l'élément déclencheur de la
crise des gilets jaunes et puis il avait
distribué quand même quelques 17
milliards d'euros pour le pouvoir
d'achat donc les Français sont pas dupe
ils comprennent bien que là Emmanuel
Macron ne veut pas prendre en compte
leur demande leur mécontentement ni sur
les 64 ans ni sur sa façon d'exercer le
pouvoir qu'il juge autoritaire et sur ce
volet justement de la démocratie est-ce
qu'il veut rouvrir le débat alors il a
créer des conventions citoyennes mais là
aussi il y a des doutes puisque les
premières tentatives et notamment la
convention citoyenne sur le climat non
pas vraiment convaincu les Français
pourtant ce président qui souhaite
vraiment laisser une trace dans
l'histoire ça on le sent il a peut-être
une carte à jouer sur le renouvellement
de la démocratie une problématique à
laquelle nombre de pays sont confrontés
à l'heure actuelle ouvrir peut-être à
des référendums une participation plus
active de la population aux décisions
publiques entamée en quelque part une
sorte de révolution démocratique en fait
c'est ce que le candidat Macron avait
proposé en 2017 donc il a peut-être
oublié ça mais son immobilisme sur ce
volet pourraient lui coûter cher parce
que en quelque sorte ça déroule un tapis
rouge à l'extrême droite et on voit une
Marine Le Pen qui est prête elle aussi
dans des bains de foule à l'heure
actuelle elle est prête à recueillir
tout simplement les voies de ses
nombreux déçus en 2027 alors je voudrais
qu'on analyse ensemble cette cette
stratégie des petits débats c'est une
braque est-ce que ça peut imprimer
infuser dans dans opinion en quelque
sorte donner le sentiment ou l'illusion
d'une démocratie plus directe encore une
fois il y a une question de période et
là je pense que les Français enfin ça se
voit elle ne sont pas prêts à écouter le
président de la République c'est trop
tôt en fait c'est comme une je parlais
de l'indigestion tout à l'heure ou un
deuil enfin c'est à dire qu'il y a une
période ça veut pas dire que le
président est condamné à ne rien faire
et à ne plus être entendu mais là c'est
trop tôt
mais cette stratégie de du dialogue du
débat c'est bien ce que demande quand
même les gens c'est à dire que l'idée du
grand débat je pense que c'était une
bonne idée puisque précisément ce que
demande les Français c'est aussi de
pouvoir
redonner du sens à la démocratie c'est à
dire que en ce moment ce qui se passe
c'est que les Français ont le sentiment
que leur représentants ne les
représentent plus c'est vraiment ça que
l'on voit dans nos enquêtes c'est à dire
les gens ont l'impression que il y a un
corps qui s'est complètement détaché du
corps social et que c'est représentants
là ont pris leur autonomie
en se détachant de leur préoccupations
et donc l'idée de pouvoir être à nouveau
entendu écouter participer au débat
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est qui
qui que les gens demandent l'idée des
référendum c'est quelque chose qui plaît
donc le grand débat
après tout il y a d'ailleurs ça avait
été utilisé il y a des aujourd'hui des
des moyens modernes qui permettent
notamment via l'intelligence
artificielle mais pas seulement de
pouvoir écouter un grand nombre de
personnes et de faire remonter beaucoup
de préoccupations donc ça ça
pourrait vraiment bien fonctionner mais
c'est pas le moment c'est encore trop
tôt c'est trop tôt si on regarde
Matthieu Suter juste en terme de de
communication il y a cette idée
peut-être de d'essayer de un peu
l'espace médiatique chez Emmanuel Macron
depuis deux trois semaines est-ce que ça
marche pour vous parce que nous on cause
avec quand même si on regarde les
chaînes d'infos alors il y a on voit les
casseroles aussi mais on parle aussi
reprenons l'exemple des images que vous
montrez à l'instant et qui font et quoi
est-ce que disait Céline en réalité on
le voit parler de du métier d'enseignant
de l'arvalorisation de leur rémunération
etc mais personne n'écoute le fond de ce
qu'il dit et personne d'ailleurs dans la
presse n'a commenté le fond du plan qui
a été proposé pour l'éducation nationale
en réalité personne vous êtes vous
forcez un peu le trait ici un peu il me
semble que il me semble que pour
l'essentiel en réalité ce n'est pas ce
qu'on retient ce qu'on regarde et même
mais ça n'est même pas ce qu'on auscule
ce qu'on regarde précisément c'est la
capacité que le président a dialogué de
nouveau avec la population on n'écoute
pas véritablement ce qu'il dit et ça
veut dire que les casseroles nous
empêchent de l'entendre pour une raison
assez simple là quand même le président
de la République c'est beaucoup exprimé
au cours des dernières semaines parce
qu'il est tout le temps sur le terrain
et qu'il fait à chaque fois un nombre de
son un calculable et on a l'impression
qu'il s'arrête tous les 10 mètres pour
redire à peu près la même chose et quand
même il a fait trois interventions ou
trois allocutions en moins d'un mois et
et encore une fois le le pouvoir a fait
le pari de la résignation de l'opinion
sans voir que plus que la résignation il
y avait une exaspération très forte et
face à l'exaspération précisément le on
attendait un petit mais à coule pas
parce que aucune des trois interventions
en fait n'a permis de faire ce qui a pas
du tout mais à coule pas on attendait un
minima un petit je vous ai compris quand
même où je vous ai entendu et à chaque
fois c'est vous ne m'avez pas compris et
sans doute d'ailleurs que j'aurais dû
parler davantage si j'avais parlé
davantage à la place de l'autre à la
place des autres on m'aurait mieux
compris donc il y a pas du tout de mea
culpa et il y a même pas d'initiatives
politiques s'il y a une situation de
crise or tout le monde s'accorde à dire
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quand même une
situation de crise Laurent Berger parle
de crise démocratique d'autres parle de
crise de régime le président de la
République l'humain a consenti qui avait
pas de crise de démocratique mais quand
même une crise sociale s'il y a une
crise face à une crise le pouvoir est
tenu quand même de prendre une petite
initiative voir une grande initiative
comme le grand débat il y a trois ans là
0 initiative donc zéro mais à coule pas
et 0 initiative ça ne peut en lutter
qu'alimenter l'exaspération qui est déjà
là alors j'étais en train de communiquer
avec avec la régie pour vous montrer un
autre trait d'image du du baromètre doxa
mascara pour Public Sénat et la et la
presse régionale sur la capacité
d'Emmanuel Macron à répondre aux
préoccupations quotidiennes des Français
parce que le le qualificatif vous le
voyez s'applique plutôt mal on est à 82
% donc c'est c'est vraiment un discrédit
très fort sur cet aspect là
Jean-Sébastien Ferjou est-ce que il y a
pas une part d'injustice après le
quoiqu'il en coûte je vais pas tout
citer mais le le chèque énergie le prêt
garanti par l'État pour les entreprises
d'artisans etc etc etc
oui certainement mais ce qui compte
c'est les aspirations des gens la
manière dont ils se projette dans
l'avenir parce que quand vous regardez
le pouvoir d'achat ou les chiffres du
chômage ils ne sont pas mauvais en soi
simplement il ne correspondent pas à ce
que les gens espèrent de leur vie ou à
ce qu'ils imaginent pouvoir être la vie
de leurs enfants et c'est ça
probablement Macron peine à comprendre
aussi parce que lui il parle juste de
chiffres et là où probablement ça se
joue sur un terrain émotionnel et donc
ça veut dire que du président protecteur
qui qu'on pouvait d'ailleurs qui se
sentait dans sa cote de popularité
pendant deux ans il l'a perdu en trois
mois avec les retraites oui mais c'est
bien gentil de faire des chèques
énergiques quand vous êtes assez
responsable et à minima on ne souhaitant
pas le changer du fait que les prix de
l'énergie est explosé en France ça fait
6 ans qu'il est Président si on avait
géré la filière nucléaire différemment
en France et si on avait réformé la
formation des prix de l'électricité je
sais bien gentil de dire regardez je
vous mets un pansement sur la blessure
que vous avez tout en étant responsable
de la blessure ou co-responsable de la
blessure elle-même je pense que les gens
ne l'oublient pas quand même il voit
aussi l'état de l'école il voit aussi et
quant au quoiqu'il en coûte on voit
aussi que ça fait exploser la date de la
France et casser largement ça n'avait
pas d'utilité économique il fallait
sauver les entreprises ça n'avait pas de
sens par exemple de fermer les commerces
qui étaient dont on savait déjà qui
n'était pas des lieux de contamination
et moi je crois surtout qu'on fait une
erreur de diagnostic sur ce qui s'est
passé pendant le grand débat oui
Emmanuel Macron a des qualités oratoires
oui il a une forme de charisme mais
pourquoi a-t-il gagné à ce moment-là
est-ce que les gilets jaunes
s'essoufflés de toute façon parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de traduction politique au
gilets jaunes il n'y avait pas de
syndicats qui avaient réussi à récupérer
le mouvement ou à l'incarner il y avait
pas de parti politique ni Marine Le Pen
ni la France insoumise ni personne
n'avait réussi
profondément différent aujourd'hui parce
que là on voit que la société française
s'est en tout cas elle est politisée il
y a l'Inter syndicale il y a l'Inter
syndicat il y a des autres qui avaient
pas vraiment d'alternative politique non
plus il y a pas d'alternative politique
mais il y a des gens qui sont présents
dans le débat et il y a des rendez-vous
démocratiques regardez d'ailleurs on va
bien voir moi je pense ça pourrait jouer
en sa faveur le rendez-vous du 8 juin
vous savez la fameuse niche
parlementaire du groupe liotte qui doit
présenter faire essayer de faire vos
propositions
alors on peut imaginer que la majorité
c'est de faire de l'obstruction
parlementaire comme l'a fait l'anus je
pense ça serait prendre un risque parce
qu'ils sont déjà crédités d'attitude
peut démocratique mais de deux choses
une soi effectivement il n'arrive pas à
empêcher le vote de cette loi-là et de
toute façon il y a pas d'autres
solutions qu'une dissolution soit pour
le coup ça lui redonne un peu d'oxygène
en disant il y a pas d'autres majorité
mais quoi qu'il en soit ça n'est pas son
il surestime son talent personnel il a
été élu parce que ça a été un accident
non mais je veux dire ça veut pas dire
qu'il est pas de talent il a compris
plus intelligemment que les autres
l'état des parties il a su se placer se
faire adouber par le système il a des
tas de qualité mais ça n'empêche pas que
c'était un alignement de planètes sans
précédent de la même manière que là il
bénéficie beaucoup de la nullité en
quelque sorte des autres ou à minima
dans ce que les Français en ressentent
et ça ne veut pas dire ça ne veut pas
dire je pense que lui imagine qu'il est
un génie politique je ne crois pas qu'il
soit un génie politique parce qu'il y a
quand même été assez fort en 2017 7%
poser de rien et avancer comme ça
c'était peut-être un coup marketing
politique plus que un coup politique
tout court moi je pense que ça fait
Blaise je rappelle à un élément de base
on l'a vu t'oublier c'est le seul sous
la 5e République avoir été élu réduit en
période comités
ou ça faiblesse c'est et je pense que
c'est ça qui fait écho au manque de
préoccupation au manque de d'atteindre
des préoccupations des Français c'est
qu'il a une vision très comptable en
fait de la société donc hop on va faire
baisser le chômage on va faire les
impôts aussi les impôts ça et finalement
les Français lui renvoient la même chose
d'ailleurs ils sont en train de préparer
une plateforme où on va savoir presque
les impôts qu'on va payer ce que ça va
nous renvoyer comme bien de la société
donc c'est une vision très
donnant-donnant
pour embarquer tout le monde la seule
vision que les gens ont trouvé c'est une
vision contre lui il y a pas de il y a
pas de vision politique
le dernier mot là-dessus sur ce que je
vous dis sur le fait qu'il ne soit
peut-être pas le génie politique il est
je lui dis pas qu'il n'a pas de qualité
oui il a été élu mais pourquoi a-t-il
été réélu parce que dans un paysage
confusion idéologique absolue les
institutions et le scrutin à de Tours
fait que celui qui est au centre gagne
plus compliqué que ça alors vous voulez
la parler mais vraiment très vite sinon
on va pas pouvoir parler des autres il a
été élu mais les deux fois face à
l'extrême droite ça ça change un peu la
donne deuxième dimension je pense que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui est de plus
grave en fait pour Emmanuel Macron c'est
l'affaissement de son socle après les
gilets jaunes sa base électorale et je
parle sous le contrôle de Céline c'était
consolide et c'était renforcé il lui
avait permis en fait de reprendre une
dynamique aujourd'hui c'est très
différent on voit bien que c'est un peu
la fin du fan club ceux qui détestaient
trois quarts de ces de ces électeurs du
premier tour sauf que depuis l'usage
même l'usage de 49-3 par exemple la
moitié de sa base a considéré que
c'était une très mauvaise manière la
moitié des Français considère que il y a
des violences policières donc son socle
s'effrite et là pour le coup c'est ce
qui fait son affaiblissement du moment
allez on parle des des personnalités
politiques parce que c'est aussi qui est
passionnant dans le baromètre au doxa
mascara vous vous testez la cote
d'adhésion et de rejet on commence par
l'adhésion avec un Édouard Philippe qui
retrouve un niveau assez élevé voilà
c'est ça il reprend 6 points il avait
perdu beaucoup de points le mois dernier
pour ceux qui ont loupé le dernier
épisode le mois dernier tous les proches
ou pas trop loin d'Emmanuel Macron en
tout cas qui pouvait être considéré
comme des soutiens de la réforme des
retraites avaient perdu énormément de
terrain donc tout le monde regagne un
peu de terrain et donc Édouard Philippe
le premier Édouard Philippe faut quand
même dire que dans notre code d'adhésion
donc on teste en tout 24 personnalités
c'est le seul dont qui a plus
d'adhésions que de rejet tous les autres
ont plus de rejet que d'adhésion en
réalité ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est que Emmanuel Macron tire vers le
bas en termes de niveau mais en tout cas
en termes de popularité la totalité des
personnalités politiques au mieux vous
voyez après Édouard Philippe qui a 40%
d'adhésion on a marine Le Pen à 34% qui
continue à gagner un peu de terre c'est
son meilleur score Bruno Le Maire 26%
Fabien Roussel qui gagne pas mal de
terrain
26% plus 4 points mais vous voyez avoir
des personnalités qui sont les plus
populaires avec des niveaux à 26 34%,
c'est franchement faible avec deux
personnalités rassemblement nationales
dans les six premiers Mathieu Suquet
c'est quoi c'est la normalisation
réussie c'est mais par ailleurs même la
séquence politique on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'ultra plasticité du
macronisme le macronisme depuis le
départ en fait se pose comme l'ennemi et
le rempart contre l'extrême droite et il
y avait dans la promesse initiale du
macronisme le dépassement la
réconciliation avec la politique et le
recul de l'extrême droite alors il n'en
est rien et en particulier depuis le
début de ce quinquennat quand même qui
n'est pas du tout le même que le
précédent il y a sur la ligne politique
un départ vers la droite je fais un jeu
à personne en disant ça en fait il y a
dans le discours politique un départ
encore plus fort vers la droite celui
qu'on entend encore plus ou presque en
ce moment c'est précisément Darmanin et
Darmanin dans le fil de ce qu'il disait
quand il dénonçait en fait la mollesse
de Marine Le Pen et on voit bien que
perçu comme ça par les électeurs de
droite alors en attendant la ligne
politique la ligne politique se déporte
la ligne politique se déporte vers la
droite le discours politique se déporte
encore plus vers la droite et le
débouché politique on le voit à travers
les sondages c'est à partir de la ligne
politique défendue quand même une
extrême droite qui ne cesse de monter
alors et puis je vais donner le podium
du rejet Éric Zemmour à 63% de rejet
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Gérald Darmanin
Sandrine Rousseau Éric Ciotti et Marine
Le Pen qui est dans les six
personnalités les les plus rejetées par
les Français je termine avec vous ifs
sensibles une intervention assez courte
si vous plaît parce que il y a un
élément qui moi m'a surpris ou en tout
cas voilà intéressé sur les
personnalités de gauche il y en a eu qui
tire son épingle du jeu dans les réseaux
sociaux c'est François Ruffin
expliquez-nous un effet ça peut paraître
surprenant compte tenu de l'ensemble des
commentaires qu'on entend d'abord sur la
France insoumise depuis les débats et
ensuite sur le et au niveau du Front
national mais sur les réseaux sociaux ou
on a un champ lexical comme je le disais
tout à l'heure qui explose sur les
termes de crise de révolution de censure
c'est François rupin truffe clairement
qui sort son épingle du jeu
il réalise l'exploit de présenter plus
de 45% d'opinion positives dans les
engagements des conversations et ça
probablement du sens parce que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas très évident
quand on observe le paysage médiatique
merci beaucoup merci Yves sensi merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
évidemment on se donne rendez-vous dans
un mois pour un nouveau baromètre au
doxa mascara pour Public Sénat et nos
confrères de la presse régionale je vous
dis à bientôt sur notre antenne